remember deep breathing is able
is able to change the biochemistry
insight
deeper than ever thought possible i want
to teach
people not the history mathematics and
language
of the school and more of that book no
i want to give them happiness strength
and health
and to never forget it anymore
we have to bring sanity back
to the people i'm gonna actually take
you to my bathroom for a second here
and there he is hey the iceman wim hof
in the house
yes how you doing ah great just great
winter is coming and i love it so i met
you
three years ago when you came to toronto
and did the uh
spent the day with you and did the
recording and all that and let me
i'm gonna i'm gonna show you something
that happened i'm gonna i'm gonna
actually take you to my bathroom
for a second here let me show you right
next to my shower
right next to my shower there it is
so when i when i go in my shower in the
morning this is what i see as a reminder
and the quote i guess
the quote's backwards but it says if we
always choose comfort
we will never learn the deepest
capabilities of our mind or
bodies there we are
yeah it's that it's that reminder it's
that reminder to stay consistent
it's been amazing watching your journey
over the past couple years because when
i
first heard of you maybe
five or six years ago um
you seem to be like this crazy guy doing
this crazy thing that
that that wasn't feasible it wasn't
possible that can't be real
and then over the years crazy even yo
you're still crazy
he's still crazy but it's more real now
in terms of all of the scientific
studies you've done and all the
interviews are done and all of the
the mainstream media attention that
you've got like it's really
starting to hit public awareness that
wow sure sure you're crazy but the ideas
aren't crazy like the ideas are actually
insane right it's like the most same
thing you could be doing
yeah man they are cold as my
ideas they cut through the speculation
they got through the comfort zone
kind of behavior they cut through the
boot
and the non sands bring bringing back
science you know i'm crazy about my wife
and my life
and everybody should do so you be crazy
about life
and feel it like love love is a sense
that you don't think you feel
that crazy you should love life
and that's the way i feel crazy i am
bloody crazy
about life about bloody crazy about this
conversation i love it man
tell me about the journey when when you
first started this
and nobody believed in you and people
said this doesn't work and
and it's only for you and it can't apply
to everybody
and it was hard to pick up the traction
like what
kept you going through all that to get
to where you are right now
that's belief that's pure belief believe
in the good
believe that i'm able as a single
person to change my mind
within a in a in a society that thinks
that what is happening that that is
normal
that the system that is sodomizing the
planet polluting the planet
the way they do becoming insensitive
that that is normal i was single-handed
single person very lonely but very
convinced
my belief made me different and see what
now is happening
i am helping millions of people with
depression
without immune diseases with performance
with anything
why because i stuck with belief
in myself and once you believe within
yourself
you will always find the light you will
always find something stronger
than the mediocre beliefs of this world
and this is what i teach now to the
people and it is simple
and it is proven by the science that it
works
that belief works now believe let me
talk about belief
when i was the last study in
michigan detroit i made
cold water coming to my skin in a brain
scanner
and then showing just by the power of my
belief
of my thought to make the cold
water my skin temperature not going
down that is our real connection
of the power of our mind but that is not
the way we are schooled
we are school to fit in a system
that is not really good for us what is
good for
us is to have a power of thought
to become happy strong and healthy
that is the love every mother would be
able to guarantee
for her kid her son and her daughter
then this world becomes a happy strong
and healthy
place and this power of the mind is now
proven through the science so it began
with a crazy idea
i don't know what it is but i will never
fit in a society
that thinks that it is normal to have
wars
cruelty to animals insensitivity to each
other
uh pollution sodomizing the planet
exploiting etc all those values
that that is normal i think it is sick
i think we have to bring sanity
back to the people to every person
accessible
and the way we are to the deeper
potential of ours
the way mother nature meant us to be
that's why we talk here right now
to give testimonial that it is through
the signs
and through the belief of one person see
what you can do
i can heal millions of people now more
than any doctor
why because i believed and believing is
going back to the core
inside of ourselves given by nature and
everybody is able to do that and that's
what i showed through the
scientific uh community evidence-based
proof
that everybody is able to tap into the
systems
with the conscious will deeper than was
stated
in all the medical books the autonomic
nervous system
immune system endocrine system lymphatic
system cardiovascular
all the mindset the mental disorders
we can now tap in and learn to regulate
our remote and to learn to bring down
inflammation especially now with the
covert 19
the fear the the anxiety
the inflammation and we cannot do
anything
that is what they make us believe
get back to your own belief get back to
the breath
we have shown in 2014 how to bring down
inflammation effectively with a group of
people
that is the real new science and they
should
applicate it bring it to the people
it's understanding of mother nature's
capability
gifted in us we bring that
to the people and for that i thank you
even
i love it i love i love it always always
energetic i love it
listen you talk about the education
system if if
you could take over see we had wim hof
day
you know one day per year was wim hof
day and every
you know 13 year old in the world would
have you
as their their teacher for the day you
could touch everybody
what would what would happen on wim hof
day what would you have these kids do
i would make everybody say feeling
is understanding i want everybody to
feel
to have a breathing session all together
through the internet all over the world
and to touch deep deeply into the
adrenal axis
activation that makes us resetting to
the way
nature meant to be and that is of deep
joy
deep peace and deep power all at the
same time
that is one then we would share it
so everybody can recognize it
that it is natural that it is a natural
feeling
that is one thing then the other one
would be
on that day the wim hof day name it
my name doesn't matter the name it's
about happiness strength and health
it's about everybody going into or the
cold shower
for five minutes and or it go into the
ice bath
and then wait for all the reactions
and see and share because that is the
understanding is feeling
and then we share and then we get back
to our senses
the way nature meant to be to be in
control
over joy over an overwhelming energy
flowing through us like as we
aware when we were in love
then this overwhelming sense of love
coming
you are trippy you don't need to know
what is love
you don't need to ask is this good yes
or no what should i do with it
do i do this for the future shall i go
and do this
no you fly that's the way i want to make
people
feel and then they understand the joy of
life
is every day there for anybody
and we found the techniques to the
openers the
the keys to get in and i want to teach
people
not the history mathematics and language
of the school
and more of that [ __ ] no i want to
give them
happiness strength and health and you
never
and to have an unforgettable experience
about it
to never forget it anymore
i love it well women i know you love
doing amas i've seen some of them
happening on reddit so
let's get some questions yogi nella's
asking
can we do the cold shower starting with
warm water then switch it to cold thank
you
yes i like hot showers man i like
hot showers not warm showers hot
showers and then cold shower
it's like a thermal shock and i love it
it's like shock therapy to myself i
i don't like half half little little
little
give me the full jawed full bald
of lightning to me and i do it
all right and right now i got made here
in my backyard
i piled up rocks big rocks like a
hundred ton
and that the highest point is three
meters
sixty almost four meters and from there
i'm able to jump into the ice the cold
water
i love it i recommend everybody to do
this
after he has trained to go into
cold showers so begin with warm
and hot hot shower then take it on to 30
seconds
then 45 seconds uh one minute one minute
etc
go into two three minutes when you reach
two
three minutes the vascular system is so
well conditioned
again you are able to go into natural
bodies of water in winter time
and then you know the power of going
into
cold water is that our bodies adapt
they adapt from the inside
so when the cold comes it is painful but
very soon the adaptive power inside
makes our body from the inside
so strong that the strength the impact
from the outside
suddenly it's not there it is mass and
then you have
peace and power and that peace and power
you exercise through regular golden
injury ice bath
is when the immune system is heightened
the endocrine system is heightened and
all
gets within your psychological control
the will and the will is a signal of
neurotransmitters
suddenly it is able to connect with the
heightened
physiology through the exercising in the
cold
then the inner power is there at will
controlled then depression has no chance
that inflammation has no chance how
simple is it
this is love this is love and we bring
it together
me and even to you as a platform i thank
you
for bringing me on i love it one of the
things that helped me at the beginning
because it can sound scary to be in a
cold shower for three minutes
you had this great printout i don't know
if you still have it on your website but
it says printer that you said put on
your shower and
i think the first is 15 seconds and you
just have to put an x
and so in your head it's okay it's only
15 seconds you can do anything for 15
seconds
and so you have to do like four or five
days at 15 seconds and then it goes to
30 seconds and then
and that kind of baby step helped me
eat it a little bit easier so it's like
okay it's not that hard
i may not end up going crazy three
minutes but it's a good starting point
to get in
and i think if you haven't done the wim
hop method you haven't done the cold
showers if you're hearing him for the
first time here today
try it like 50 you could do anything for
15 seconds
just get in have your warm shower and at
the end just go cold for 15 seconds
do you still have that pdf like download
sheet on your website
oh yeah i know we we develop we have
developed a
app now and it is for free
we want everybody to be able to access
to all the goods we found to all
scientifically endorsed uh best
ways which are most accessible and most
strong to do most effective
so there is a free app go to the free
app
and then you will be gradually let
into all the practice you want all the
depth
and we go further than science thought
possible
and it's all coming now to you you just
take it on
first baby step becomes an adult step
very soon
within 10-15 days your cardiovascular
system
will make your stress go away and your
energy go
up way up and weigh down the stress
because you are in control than it is
and the app is called i think wim hof
method and the logo is
is your your three symbols right yeah
yeah perfect i love it okay let's get
very clear very clear
i know many people 150 000 people
who cured of their ailments and of
anything you can
ask all the questions it's really
miraculous
because life is a miracle and i
came to to life experience because
when i was 12 i was a seeker
at that moment i pledged myself i'm
gonna do
something about this world i don't know
how i don't know what
i'm going to do it and the 12 year old
are very strong because they are very
simple and pure
and then when they hit something they go
to the heart
and then it comes to the mind and then
they begin to think
and then they stumble upon upon real
things
to really really connect and tranquilize
what they have begun
and i found it in the water in the fire
in the water
that the mines were stupefied saying
this is it
nothing works in feeling and then
i i did this for 25 years then i came
across the
a newspaper television they began to
challenge me
i did 26 of world records and then the
scientists came in and they saw me doing
things
not possible according to scientific
literature
and then i said but you are the iceman
they said
that is not normal but only you can do
it i say
no no no here you make a mistake
everybody is able to do it and so was
you
because it's about love it's about love
for nature for mother nature
and mother nature equipped us to be in
harmony with nature
to be strong to be happy to be vibrant
to be light beings of light not of dark
to be a beings of light not heavy
to fly like when you are in love you fly
you are because that's your hormonal
system
and that hormonal system through the
exercise in the cold
and the breathing exercises then it the
hormonal system comes
within your control then you become
lives
and you fly like you are in love
this time in love with life
now you've got a new book out too the
wim hof method
what i mean people go to amazon pick it
up check out your website
what's what's covered in the book what
what can people expect
in the book there's the whole the whole
story
like i'm a simple guy yet i'm changing
the world
so can you by being simple
to have access in connection with your
deeper self
to be in love with life
that is who you really are that is
the way you bless everything and
everybody you encounter
every moment every step
is a dance every word is a song
and it's poetry it's all coming from you
just from being
you don't need to think about it just be
it
be in love of life from now on every day
when you wake up
you got a new opportunity to rise to the
best
to rise more than thoughts to transcend
thoughts and be in love and if you don't
know how to do it
get into the book then you see a person
lost
in this society beginning in the dark
in the valley and then climbing up
through all the
hardships of life all the depressions
or little money the children
the suffering the death of his wife
of the love is life coming back
like a phoenix big and i'm here to tell
you
we have changed signs
i did all the records i got the guts
because i went
into the gods the gods were saying
you can do it that god
brings cuts and with that you will be
able
to defy any fader any blockage
any inhibition any problem you get to
your goals and the goal
is love i love it well the book is
called the wim hof method we'll link
that up on the youtube
description below for those who are
watching the replay let's take a couple
more questions
how many times a day do you do your
breathing technique
like now this is deep breathing what i
do is
between the conversations i bring
in more oxygen than normal
to feed the deep tissue to become
alkaline when it becomes alkaline
then it becomes very good a good
condition
of the biochemical uh say
condition for the neurotransmitters the
nervous system to be there to do what i
want
because my nervous system is my will
my conscious will is the ruling through
my system
right now i want to be very clear i want
to be
on the top of wisdom coming from nature
i have been in nature i want to
translate it i want to take away
your doubt in any way created by a wrong
biochemistry inside
just by the word by my belief
by being here my presence that's who i
am how many times you learn to feel
deep breathing remember deep breathing
is able
is able to change the biochemistry
inside
deeper than ever thought possible we
have shown this
in the university we have shown this in
blood through
we have shown this by being injected
with a bacteria and have no problems
with it
because we are in control over our
immune system and the life
force itself how
conscious deep breathing besides of that
if you want to go in the morning on
empty stomach
very deep into your lymphatic system
which is the storage
of garbage of acidity of the body
if you want to go into that then you
follow
the protocols for our breathing
exercises
all evidence based in the university
to go deeper than thought possible in
science
and it's cleaning the lymphatic system
it's cleaning the garbage storage
of your body and then afterwards you
feel light
you feel great and you will be able to
be in command
with your will which was a signal
in control you are the captain of your
soul
the captain on your own ship you can
sail the waters
anywhere you want it's beautiful
so as much as you need breathing
remember you are the captain of your
soul
the captain on your own ship to sail all
the waters of life
and if you don't feel that breathe and
as i
very eloquently say breathe
i think too like having reminders that
you put around your house this is why i
love your
the pdf so much is because every time i
go for a shower there i stuck it
on my shower so it's a reminder oh yeah
today i have to have the shower
right so i haven't done like i was just
looking over here i've set up these
little stickers so there's a little
sticker here
on my door this is my bathroom door so
this is my reminder to breathe
uh-huh so every time i go to the
bathroom i i'm hit with that reminder
breathe right right and a practical
and and we've got a sign on our door uh
as we leave the the the house
that says breathe too so it's just
setting up little reminders
at some point it becomes like i've done
that so many times and now it's
it's automatic but at the beginning i
think you need to
train yourself because you don't have
those habits built in so so having
little things
i i we need to have some wim hof
stickers i want to put a wim hof sticker
up on my door
so every time i go in the door you
remember breathe breathe breathe
that that is too much honor but i i love
it of course
and anywhere where i can help a man
even and all the listeners and all the
viewers
we will change the world together
we got that done and we need to be
reminded of that
we will remind you we are doing the
science we keep on
we not just have belief we have control
over our deeper potential more than was
a thought possible in science we
are a hat of science this world needs
change we are to change we are the new
windows
look into it and we bring it on and now
we do this side by side
boom i love it next pregnant can they do
whim half method
no deep breathing you can do conscious
breathing
that is very good to alkalize your blood
which comes and goes to the womb
goes to the fetus will feed the child
with enriched alkaline alkalized blood
very good and then
the cold shower amazing amazing for
people who are pregnant
cold shower is amazing it contracts and
opens
the vascular system ultimately then the
blood flow goes back better
through the system heart rate goes down
so stress goes down and the energy
will reach the cells the better with
energy i mean
nutrients vitamins and oxygen will reach
the cells
better that means not only of the mother
but also the fetus and that means
that the stress also there on cell
biological level
also goes down that means actually it
will spike up
in being okay then the stress goes down
it's amazing and i know you're big on
proving all of this too it's not just
ideas but you like having it backed up
by research and data and science
what what are some of the new things
that you're working on right now
scientific studies or things that have
just come out that you're really happy
about or proud of
yes just today came out a new study
out of the university uh uh of san
francis uh
no a university of california san
francisco
uh department uh dna
and uh uh what yeah
with the best top researchers right now
it's a
done with dr elisa ippell
with the co-author with the nobel prize
winner on the
dna on the telomere effect
she is doing right now a big study with
us
on this method on 140 women
who are doing uh the wim hop method
and they don't know that they are doing
it and that they did it
but that doesn't matter it's about the
effect not about the name
we always say in the netherlands that
doesn't matter the label
if the wine is good it doesn't need a
label so
here we are doing a study on the dna
and the telomeres and the heat shock
proteins that's the cell's protection
so for inflammation not to get into the
cell
so we are doing that revolutionary it's
going to be
revolutionary december we get the
results
with san francisco and that's one the
dna study then another study
we do it on depression very effective
how to bring depression down that's what
causes depression is inflammation
we bring it down and thus depressing
does
not emerge we will show that in
the studies another study is in detroit
the wayne state
university we are doing a study on
bipolar uh state of mind
and how to bring it up through the
method
another study is done uh four studies
here in the netherlands with the
university of rocbolt
on information in various types of
inflammation
and it shows spectacular results on how
to bring down
inflammation before thought impossible
and now it's possible so we uh in 2014
we did a study and we
shattered the foundations of science
back then showing that we can beat
inflammation with natural methods
inflammation by natural methods and now
the same study has been
done bigger and they got the same
results and
even more so all this is coming out very
soon
and then we got more foundation i want
more
uh studies to be done i love
people to be critical because that will
polish the diamonds of the truth
and the truth is we are having
all of us a greater potential insight
and now we have found the keith and we
only want to give
and hand over the key to you to open up
to your greater potential and feel happy
strong and healthy
everybody in the world
how many studies you think you've done i
i don't know uh myself
between 10 and 20 about
and uh yes investigations experiments
research are done and every time it's
the outcomes are outside of what
was written in books to be possible as
humans
to do so we have to go on with this
we have found the keys but we have to
open up more
and find our happiness strength and
health
in our control and conditionally
and this is what i want i want study
study study studies
why there is so much more than what i
found
and i'm trying to tell this to everybody
it's not about me
it's not about the ice man it's about
being voiced man
i like it i just think people can easily
get caught up in the energy that you're
putting off
and not realize that there's a lot of
science behind it and that you
care deeply about the science and the
data and the studies and are always
pushing more to get more researchers on
board and more universities and
and more you know peer-reviewed medical
journals to look at this
is there is there a place is there a
place for all the research like you have
a place on your website where all the
studies that you've done
are there that people can dive in most
of the studies are
uh being published and uh
on the website and very clearly there
and so
uh it's all transparent and there is a
big community
about 150 to 200 000 people
talking to each other how they killed
how how
what are the benefits like no nonsense
like a no nonsense hospital we don't
need doctors we need to heal
and we heal all together we heal each
other
we bring a wisdom from nature to each
other
through common sense because of what
happens in the pharmaceutical industry
what happens in the hospitals
it doesn't make sense we make sense
we are people we have to bring back
the common sense the wisdom of nature
into common sense again and then we get
confidence
and that confidence nobody is able to
shatter we become
strong like rocks everybody and
everybody else will see it
that you are strong then they come to
you when they are confused
or when they are depressed when they
don't feel good
when they don't see their purpose of
life they come to you
because they feel it because it makes
sense
and then you just radiate you talk with
the person
you give them confidence that love has a
right
the love for the life the craziness a
feeling
that is stronger than confusion
there we are i love it someone someone's
asking is ice bath better in the morning
or evening
does it matter i do it several times
a day and uh i just follow my feeling
so in the morning it's good after the
breathing
my phone fell we got you we got you
yeah it's all an awkward installation
here
but we do i always do my best this is
what i got just before this i had
uh cool what was it uh
cool cast or something and
and before that i had a different
interview and that was in different
places so i'm doing this
with my phone right now but the message
is
clear when i do my ice baths
anytime when you do it you are going to
the deepest of yourself
remember that it doesn't matter if you
can do it before you sleep because you
are anxious
with thoughts and stress hormone
cortisol
worries if you go into the ice bath that
is the only time that you cannot think
it will relieve you it will break the
cycle
you break the loop and then you come to
your sense
you become strong and you sleep like a
rose
that in the morning it will invigorate
you
for the rest of the day and it always
brings peace
in the evening in the morning it does
not matter
it's always transcending our thoughts
our words our daily life a way of
thinking
and that is just great because we are
great
i love it okay someone's asking is it
possible to teach the children
or could it be dangerous no the children
will feel it for themselves my child
when he was one year old and he is he
wants to come in now
he is now three years old my oldest of
37
my youngest is three years old hey man
i'm a dog
i can tell you yeah the thing is the
thing is
when he was one year old every morning
he stood
in front of the door waiting in the
morning
going barefoot on the frozen lawn
every morning when he was one years now
he's three years he begins to think
now he says no puppy there lift me up
let me out
but still he is very capable of going
outside
in the court i let him do it by
himself when i'm sitting in the iceberg
sometimes he comes to me
he's playing with the ice water it's no
problem
and then he goes in by himself
i'm not forcing it it's like a when a
little zebra is born
in within 30 minutes it's able to run
with the mother
to go into the dangers of life you need
to run
that the mammalian principle of a dad
doing that makes the little child mimic
and they got the power to do so and then
when they do so when they go into this
on the frozen lawn and all these things
by themselves
nothing happens my my little child ate
chicken when he was young they
ate everything that is testing the
immune system
i let it be it was like horrible almost
take it man okay a couple of times i saw
it
my it is the best for the gut bacteria
i'll tell you that your nose nature
knows
so they mimic there's no problem don't
force them
they mimic if you love it they want to
follow the love
someone's asking are you planning to do
another face-to-face guided training in
the future
sure and there are a lot a lot of them
lots of them
and uh i'm planning now
a 12 months sort of
what was my son told me and i said yeah
here you got the content
i will bring people to the deepest of
their physiology
within 12 months deeper than any book is
able to show
that sorry but my things don't come from
books
my my things come from nature and it is
yet to come into books the latest book i
wrote
is about my life but also very good
uh links and techniques
that really makes a big difference in
daily life
if you just follow it and then the
insights
on the autonomic level on the atomic
level
on the level of the dna of our ancestry
the purpose it's all in there and so
my teachings are every day different
because i
teach every day different because i
learn every day different
i progress more more more it's not only
that
we are ahead of science
we want now to bring that what is ahead
of science
now to the most broad uh
a a broad a kind of audience
of the world and how to do that is every
time
try try try link link link
two podcasts and yeah i'm i'm in
fatigable
in doing that until i find that the
message
is crossed over i will keep on
we are born to be happy strong and
healthy and
uh as they in the u.s they say with the
route 266
we are born to be wow
having gone through your toronto event
uh
it's definitely worth it one to learn
from you obviously and have somebody in
front but also the community like
everybody who shows up
are just the most warm amazing awesome
crazy people but it's a great vibe
and it's often hard to find a lot of
people if you're talking about doing
cold showers and
and breath work people think you're nuts
well here are a bunch of other people
who are just as nuts as you and this is
great community that you bring together
at the events
um so that was that was a super fun
experiment talk about kobe quickly how
how how big a deal do you think this is
i know you've done a whole bunch of
experiments
with injecting yourself with different
uh illnesses yeah covet 19
covet 19 is based on inflammation the
damaging factor of
covet 19 is inflammation
the corona the corona virus creates
inflammation
that is the damaging factor of the covet
of the corona virus now the question is
okay we know that we know that the
the inflammation markus of covet 19
is interlochen number one number six
number eight and number 11. those are
the damaging factors
in the so-called cytokine storm
that is the damaging factor to the lungs
inside and it begins with coughing they
can say
some kinds of uh uh
symptoms the question is can we bring
the fl the damaging factor of covert 19
when it starts can we bring it willfully
down
suppress the inflammatory markers
the damaging factor the cytokine storm
and all the doctors listening you know
what i'm talking about
but i made it simple and now in 2014
they injected all of us with e coli
bacteria
which is also causing the same
inflammation markers the same damaging
factor
and we brought it all down as the first
ones in medical history
a whole group of people first of all
thousands of people
could not do that they all became
controlled
three two hours three to six hours sick
and then suddenly 12 people i trained
in a retreat like you have been
in that way in four days i brought him
and then i trained them and then i we
brought him to the hospital
to take the injection where thousands of
people became sick
all the 1200 percent score
did not became sick
and then they looked inside the blood
what happened
through the breathing techniques they
had suppressed
effectively within 15 minutes
the inflammation the inflammatory
markers
so what i tell know as big what is big
is
that what is locking down all the world
and i challenge
any doctor and professor because we did
a study already
and you can compare it i i tell them
there's no need well for covet to exist
when because when it happens you can do
breathing exercises
and bring down effectively the
inflammation
they should get into that this is not
just a
bold expression exclamation of me
this is coming from richard
and being published in the past of
papers of the world
the proceedings of the
procedures of the academy of sciences in
america
and nature i've done that
it began with me with one person drop
out from school
clever casting sign flabbergasting
scientific understanding of what we are
capable of and then i said no it's not
only me
it's everybody but you gotta do it
just look it up and in the end you don't
need to look it up
just do it because feeling is
understanding
and that is big every day every day that
belief
is now able to touch bottom inside
our psychology is able now to go
over our physiology this is the new
study the latest study i showed
psychology over physiology brain
over body interoception
through thinking cold water does not
make your skin temperature while being
exposed
to cold water your skin temperature does
not go down
because you think it not to be
that is through your signaling of your
conscious will
entering into the stress mechanisms
making yourself strong from the inside
just by the signal you are the commander
then it happens a sequence of
biochemical processes and your body
becomes stronger
and the cold is not able to make the
temperature
of your skin going down
and that is the control of these stress
mechanisms
that is the new science and that is big
and we should
every day remember that we actually have
much bigger potential inside of
us at least to become happy
strong and healthy because we want so
and because it is time and that is every
morning
so don't forget anybody of you to rise
not to happiness strength and health and
if it is not there
take the culture and remember get this
connection
of your will with your body because it
is
you have to learn to own your own
mind not the way we are schooled because
this is done it's obsolete ctrl
alt delete that is the system of before
the kings and the presidents and
everybody is all
what we are here for is to bring
happiness strength and health
to everybody in the world we don't need
kings
we don't need nobody we need nature
mother nature
we need to be happy strong and healthy
all of us through the science
show so it's all there wake up
to that then you will bless everybody
and yourself we're getting asked a lot
of questions about
uh food and diet what you eat does it
does it matter for the breath work or
the shower
what what what's your recommendations on
diet on diet
don't eat too much eat when you
feel you are hungry when the appetite
makes your eyes big
when your body becomes ah because
it's a very good uh feeling uh
to feel that when you are hungry then
you're gonna last for your food when you
feel that all the enzymes all the
biochemical processes
the metabolic processes inside the body
are ready to receive
not if you go through your mind but go
through the body's feeling
of appetite or deep appetite what
happens
when that happens is that you become
more alert
you get a neurological revision every
day
so don't eat because you have to
don't eat because you think you need a
breakfast and then a lunch
then a dinner and then in between
because it is normal
it is not normal you know what's normal
feeling that you need
fruit that you understand from the
inside
i feel ah that's why i need
then eat with all the lust and make it a
party
every day any kinds of food
meat veggies like it doesn't matter
it matters it matters there is uh
we are we are like omnivores
but very little meat very little meat is
needed
we need a lot of uh veto uh
a vital element that means light
light is more in plants directly
stored than the meat in meat the
food the greens are already consumed and
they
have a lot of photosynthesis that is
light
pure light inside so
meat reduce reduce meat
because it needs more processing than uh
plants
and plants are able to produce more
molecules
they are able to produce more energy
thus
in the body and it's just better also
for the planet
and it's also about cruelty to animals
man we eat
living beings why we are living beings
so take on what is alive plants
is okay and animals say
reduce it but not over indulging into
meat
no no no no it's like you eat yourself
it's not a nice thought
don't do it and you know we don't no
longer
live with the cows in the street it's
not wild
it's all because of our thoughts it's
not
the you know this relationship we cut
little cops and then eat them
i'm not a lie man i'm a tiger
[Laughter]
i love it well the book is called the
wim hof method again on youtube we'll
link that in the description below to go
check it out
when final message for my audience to to
close this interview up what do you got
hey man i love you all this is about
love you can see that i'm
sharing common knowledge and there is so
much more
and i'm doing all the science and before
i go
from this planet to a much better place
i will make this planet the most
beautiful spot
in the whole view of the universe why
because love will be brought to this
planet and now we are doing this
together
okay wake up every day do your best and
the best will come
because that's the way we are built i
love it wim hof the book is the wim hof
mess it thank you man thank you
appreciate it all the love you're
putting out and can't wait to talk to
you soon
if you want to see my one-on-one
experience with wim hof at his session
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
that's cool